i'll call this hearing to order
i think
all of you know that um we lost one of
our members
uh
over the weekend
and i'd like to ask that we rise
senator hennessey
on
1445 relative to broadband matching
grant initiative
thank you madam chair and members of
house finance it's good to see everybody
i am aaron hennessey senator for
district one northern half of grafton
and all of coast county and i am here to
introduce senate bill 445 which makes
some technical changes to
senate bill 85 which we passed last year
that established the broadband matching
grant fund and this fund was originally
set up to
use arpa funds
to our towns or our counties or our
providers for um bringing broadband to
the
homes that don't currently have it and i
think the um
pandemic highlighted the the need for
broadband in the state for with everyone
working from home or schooling from home
what the senate did this year was to
change that 50-50 to 75-25
so
we're we're matching more of the federal
funds against the local funds so that'll
help a lot more projects get done
especially for our communities that are
using their local funds to do the
expansion
and it also uh allocated all of the
122 million dollars that we received
from the federal government into the
fund
the fund the wording on the allocation
does allow for
the department bea to
come to fiscal if they would like to
spend the dollars for any other purpose
that is um
follows the rules of the federal
government and there are purposes that
i'm sure the department can tell you
about that may happen
um in the future we are expecting
another 100 million dollars for
broadband expansion and other um
connectivity expansion so there are
other opportunities to perhaps add money
to this fund
but anyway i'm happy to take questions
are there any questions uh yes
representative heath
thank you madam chair and thank you
senator will this um finally bring the
north country
fully on board
just i can't imagine what it's been like
for families that haven't had access um
during the last two years it's it is
very difficult for for a lot of people
there are plans underway to advance
getting
all perhaps hopefully all of new
hampshire hooked up
i do believe that there's enough money
in the fund to do that in the entire
state of new hampshire and my apologies
i did forget that there is an amendment
um
one three five one s that adds one word
to uh section two b of the of the bill
and that's um
uh if you're looking at the amendment
it's the word successful and i'm trying
line 11 thank you
a provider who successfully
um challenges an applicant's eligibility
so it just adds successfully in there
represent representative uh sure my mind
my mind is blank edwards
okay uh thank you madam chair i i think
i have just two questions um one of them
is related to the phrase make ready
process
and i'm unfamiliar with that term does
that need to be defined somewhere in
statute or is that such a well
understood term by normal people that i
i don't know the answer to that question
i'm sorry i think um someone who
um
is more familiar perhaps from the
department could answer that because
they have rules set up already for this
sure okay uh and then
i i'm glad there's an amendment to um
that that picks up the word successfully
a provider who successfully challenges
because when i read that multiple times
i didn't quite understand what we were
trying to do there
so so
are you able to walk us through an
example
to help us help me understand
what what's happening there if if if
there's an application
and the f and the and the
construction has already begun
but it gets successfully challenged
meaning
what what kind of a successful challenge
would there be and and what are the
ramifications so um and again some
people behind me could probably answer
the questions to the what a successful
challenge would look at like from an
industry level but my understanding is
that if there's already a project
happening and then somebody wants to get
funds for another project that would
duplicate the same efforts across
to the same homes or to the same
businesses
the provider that is already doing it
could
could challenge that that wouldn't
happen and then if it's successful then
that person applying for those funds
would not get those funds
all right at the layman terms no i like
that i'll i'll
ask again thanks
are there any further questions uh
representative turcotte
thank you madam chair thank you senator
for taking the question um could you
explain to me
why the 50 50 is not adequate and why
you're looking for 75.25
so the um just looking at the numbers of
of the money that's coming into state
for broadband we have enough money to
match 75 percent
from this fund to the local 25
or provider 25
so we don't need we there's enough money
sorry
go ahead please
uh senator
i just had a curiosity question once
that once this is installed
using
a municipality and arpa money who owns
the who owns it does it convert to what
the operating s operator at that i
think
with um and
i don't know if a locality would want to
oper own and operate their own lines so
i imagine it would be with the
operator but that i think that's whoever
the contract is with i would have to
specify that
uh rep representative lynn yes i i have
uh a question sort of along the um the
same lines uh as the last one and that
is
is the
is it your understanding that a
municipality
is either legally
limited to only contracting with one
with one provider for the municipality
or if if not legally limited is that
typically
the way
municipalities operate
well i don't sorry thank you for the
question it looks like
right
now but i know that if
if currently if an operator provides the
service that's required the upload and
download speeds
and again i'm not a techie person so i
don't understand all that side of stuff
but if there's already provider that
does that
to to the homes in your community then
there wouldn't be another provider that
comes in to do that same
service
that's my understanding somebody behind
me might be able to correct me on that
thank
you representative petrie
thank you madam chair
uh it's not really a question this is an
answer uh
in my town we it was what they call a
franchise fee
and the
the
provider
pays the town
a certain amount of money
to operate in our town okay so that's
that's the way our town works and i
thank you representative
uh thank you madam chair actually i
think i'll wait for
somebody with the technical knowledge
together another question
no offense taken
[Laughter]
by the way don't ask me those technical
questions okay just just in case you
were thinking that
i should know
are there any further questions
okay
oh i'm sorry representative irf didn't
see you
uh thank you madam chair i thank you
senator
just out of curiosity why is section one
necessary and why is the word
appropriation used
these funds can already be approved if
i'm not mistaken by the fiscal and
governor and council to go for this
purpose
so um thank you for the question
representative section one uh senate uh
when we drafted this and senate finance
agreed to keep this in here because the
state already has these monies and we
want to make sure that if any of these
funds are used for another purpose other
than the broadband matching grant
initiative that
the legislature has an opinion on that
and they would go before fiscal to say
yes you know
we see that you are meeting the intent
of the initiative and we recognize that
you need these funds
for overhead or
to do this other
project
hodge hodgdon is that similar is that
close enough
well you hit it on the head
okay
thank you uh members of the committee my
name is chris hodgst and i'm comcast
vice president of government affairs
here in new hampshire and and i'm
just here to offer our support
for
uh this legislation and uh really
in an effort not to repeat anything as
senator hennessey said
um i'll just
provide a couple thoughts and
make myself available to answer any
questions that you may have i as she
said that the primary impetus for this
particular piece of legislation after
the legislature adopted what started out
as senate bill 85 and then became a part
of the the budget last year
is that when policymakers created the
current statute there wasn't a clear
understanding of whether or to what
extent or what the federal guidance
would look like
for the federal dollars that were coming
down the pike we we knew and could
expect that there would be federal
resources for broadband but we didn't
fully understand
what
constraints or guardrails may exist and
this
legislation seeks to just better align
what was passed last year with what the
final guidance was for
arpa's capital projects fund and what
the statute says
for
the infrastructure and jobs act
we don't have final
guidance yet on that ladder bill but the
statute's far far more specific than
arpa so
i think just
generally speaking this may answer a
couple of the questions that were asked
providers in the state have done a good
job over the last few years
narrowing in on that last three four
five percent of unserved but while
that's a relatively small percentage
we're talking about tens of thousands of
homes
and and some businesses even in the
state that continue to lack
uh broadband it's a reasonable estimate
is anywhere between 20 and 30 000
remaining locations in the state uh and
it's not just the north country although
the north country certainly has its
share of unserved pockets
interior grafton interior sullivan parts
of cheshire
you know even a few
remaining pockets in hillsborough and
merrimack are are unserved and
legislation like this will help
to uh get over that hump so that we can
finally
substantially reduce those numbers
so
our ask or urge of you is to support
this
the amendment um well i haven't seen it
before today
seems to make perfect sense uh the
purpose of
the challenge provision is to ensure
that these dollars are only spent where
they're truly needed and we we have 95 6
of the state that's covered served by
providers
we want to ensure that we
focus these dollars and these
partnerships in areas where people are
truly lacking service while
220 plus million dollars is a
fantastically large sum of money
these are very very expensive projects
it is not unusual to see
construction costs run
60 70 80 000 a mile
and when you're in a rural area with
four or five six
homes
maybe eighty percent of
uh folks will ultimately decide to take
a service you can imagine just how
challenging the business model is so
with that i'll conclude my
testimony and i'd be happy to answer
any questions that you may have
uh represent turcotte did you wish to
ask your question
sure thank you madam chair uh the
question i had is uh to be clear
uh a community or street or whatever
that's already served by broadband would
not be eligible for this that's correct
it's so broadband is a very binary
exercise you either have it or you don't
the way that the new hampshire law is
currently structured
is to look at it in that fashion it it
is a house by house analysis of where
service is available where service isn't
available and the and this anticipates
directing those funds in areas that are
unserviced on service unserviceable
thank you
representative petrie yeah thank you
madam chair thank you for taking one
question
some of these really remote places
wouldn't it be easier to just do a
satellite
it may be and as a practical matter
satellite either low earth orbit or
geosynchronous is currently available
in virtually all places it's not
universally available because of sort of
peculiar peculiarities of geography
the federal
funds are really intended
to
support the the construction of wired
terrestrial networks
uh it's
they are
structured in such a way
to
for all intents and purposes direct
funds towards terrestrial networks and
away from
satellite
that's not the case of all funds you may
have heard of what is known as the
ardoff which is an fcc program rural
digital opportunity fund
viasat and a couple other satellite
providers are recipients of those funds
so that's a another source of federal
money that is available for
those non-wired
services
representative earth
so that kind of answered my question but
to follow up on that
why is there such a strong bias to
hardwired connections when not only are
satellite connections available now but
more sophisticated ones and faster ones
are coming down the pike if i'm not
mistaken yeah i think what we've seen
i began in the industry in 2006 and at
that time
customer bandwidth consumption was in
the
high megabits a month low gigabits a
month
it's now nearing a terabit a month
thousand gigabits and the speeds offered
by these networks our network is 500
times faster
than
[Music]
what we were offering 15 years ago so
and those enhancements have been made
because the
demand the consumer demand for bandwidth
is just continues to skyrocket we see
a doubling of the utilization of our
network every 18 months
and
modern terrestrial broadband networks
offer levels of service capacity
and
have shown themselves to be broadly
accepted by the consumer marketplace in
a way that we just haven't seen with
satellite
and i think that this decision to
structure
these arpa funds and the bead program
which is coming down the road is just a
recognition of that on the part of
and there was a question about make
ready um if i may um sorry so make ready
is the process by which utility poles
are literally made ready
for an additional attachment like a
broadband provider to go on that pole
it is a process regulated by the public
utilities commission
now in part doe and it is uh it's a bit
of term of art but it is a well
understood process
access to utility poles is one of the
few remaining monopoly choke points in
the telecommunications industry there's
only
one set of polls by and large in any
given right away so it remains a
regulated process and uh and how that
occurs
is is well understood
representative leishman thank you madam
chair
so
i have a question concerning the service
here is now i live in peterborough and
there's some areas as you know probably
that don't have coverage in peterborough
and sharon in hillsborough county
but as recently as last fall
a company called consolidated
came into our neighborhood put
underground cables in and presently
comcast serves our neighborhood
and i asked the service provider why
were they providing
additional service
and they said well the federal
government is paying for this so we're
adding this additional service to your
neighborhood it didn't make any sense
for me at the time is that what you're
referring to another federal program to
provide
service to communities that don't have
it but we already have it but somebody
is paying for consolidated to put this
service in so if you go to the fcc's
website and look under ardoff rural
digital opportunity fund rdof you'll see
a map of areas in the state of new
hampshire where
certain providers have sought and been
awarded funds
those areas should not be in any area
where there's already
another competitive provider
and by and large that's the case i mean
they went through a process to make sure
like
new hampshire statute contemplates they
went through a process to make sure that
these dollars just weren't spent where
they weren't needed and by and large
that's the case
uh there are areas
sharon there are areas
of green field there are areas
uh
to your to north and west of you where
that are ardoff recipients so i
i suspect that there's just confusion
about exactly
why there was construction going on in
in your neighborhood because
for the most part
rdof funds were not
invested by the fcc for
areas like peterborough where there's
thank you thank you madam chief
representative
okay
i thought i was having a hard time today
madam chair all right thank you very
much uh madam chair the question i have
is that in cowards county there are
areas where a
not on main roads but on side roads
where a home would want to have
broadband but the situation exists that
a provider
refuses because a quarter it the last
connection is like a quarter or a half
mile down the road in
any and they say that unless all of the
homes along that stretch
want it they will not provide it to that
boom
will this bill clarify that situation
so i believe it will because what's
happening is
you know every provider has a different
business model but they try to apply
their model
to the market opportunity that they see
in a given area and that given area can
be as small as
one home a street with a few homes or a
whole town
and they do an analysis of whether or
not they can
make the numbers work and if they can't
then they can if they can they can and
on the margins i have absolutely seen
situations
uh i mean in representative leishman's
community there was a time
when we
sought to work out a similar deal off of
route 136 where we essentially were
trying to make the numbers work by
figuring out who's interested who's not
interested
you know we never had a you have to hit
this number to make it work
but it was it was an effort to figure
out can we make it work
and uh so you see that uh
as
you know that goes to my earlier point
about how really
deploying broadband is a pretty binary
exercise you try to figure out whether
you can make it work for a given house
or or not and that's
that's one provider's way of trying to
figure out if they can make it work
thank you
representative edwards
uh thank you madam chair
um
on the amendment
do you have it in front of you okay so
i'm gonna ask you to
paint a picture for me because these
these words are not creating a scenario
in my head
a provider who successfully challenges
an application's eligibility for funding
because the construction has commenced
shall complete construction as soon as
practical and without undue delay
who who are the parties in this sentence
and what what's happening here
so the parties as i said the make ready
process is a regulated
process it includes timelines by which
uh the
various entities are involved in
construction have to or should comply
so those entities are the poll owners
which are typically
sure so those entities
in the in the make ready process those
entities are typically the incumbent the
two poll owners are one poll owner the
incumbent electric utility the incumbent
telephone utility and then whoever the
provider is who wants access to the
polls
so that's that's one of the
uh that's part of the process of getting
these networks built is is making those
polls ready and then the other party
uh to it is is the firm who's doing the
work the construction aspect of it and
then to a lesser extent you know any
sort of government engagement through
permitting
uh that that's
almost never
a constraining factor in construction
but it's
thank you for the effort i still don't
understand the sentence i don't know
like
a provider who successfully challenges
right
who is that if if if they're the ones
doing the work
right then why would they challenge
their own work
because the rest of the sentence then
tells them
that even if they're successful in
challenging themselves
they still have to complete the
construction as soon as possible that's
the way that reads yeah let me step back
and
maybe better explain it so
has a policy statement that says we want
to invest only in areas that are
unserved that would otherwise not be
able to receive broadband
and the way that you
ensure that those dollars are being
spent only in areas that need it
is that you create because of the lag
time
and the the complexity of how many
providers are in the marketplace
providing service the surest way to
ensure that you're not spending money
where it should not be spent
is to have a process where a provider
can say
i'm already providing service there i
made the investment we're providing
service to customers
or we're currently building in that area
and the currently building piece can be
months it takes time to do this there's
some seasonality and then there's that
make ready process to get the job done
so right now to give you an example
so we currently have
under construction
network that includes 4 800 utility
poles in the state of new hampshire it's
about 125 miles of infrastructure
and that is like currently
you know budgeted by us to complete the
work actively in construction
that's a large i mean that's
in a relatively large town that's an
entire town's worth of construction road
miles
so what the state law says is we we do
not want to use scarce federal resources
there in those areas we want the private
sector to expend their money
and build their networks we want to
focus the money in areas that are
that are truly needed and that's that's
what the challenge process allows it it
allows a provider to say
we already serve area a or
we're already
building currently building in area b
and as this was working its way through
the senate the question was all right
well
like what does that mean what does under
construction mean so
this language explains what it means
which is it's
an area where the make ready process has
begun which is a well understood process
that has
regulatory oversight by the puc and doe
and and then it
we
language was added to ensure that
once construction begins
it's done in a an expeditious manner
which is the language used as
must be shall be completed
as soon as practical and without until
do do delay because there was a desire
to just make sure that
all these areas
get the service that
that's coming to them
so that's what that uh that language
does all right thank you
uh and my apologies if this was covered
but um i'm just thinking of shelburne
and i know that's not part of your area
but um
so the dynamic has changed in other
words
i'm thinking they were
lacking broadband services for a
considerable length of time in my
understanding
was that there was not enough demand
or enough custom potential customers to
provide that service and
and
this changes that is that
correct increase the environment right
shelburne's a good example i'm not we
don't serve shelburne but i'm
fairly well bring it up yeah uh familiar
with it um
yeah so in the last few years the
spectrum which is the
cable company that serves
the anderson valley valley
has
begun to build out into shelburne
stretching out from
gorham
east
but there are still areas of town that
are not covered by their network and
then the incumbent telephone provider
consolidated has done the same so what
this
program the broadband matching grant
initiative allows is that for those
unserved areas a provider can
whether it's in partnership with the
community
there'll be a partnership of some sort
between the community the provider
and the state to secure the resources to
build out those areas that are not
currently served that's right it may
follow up yes you may so um
and if this is covered again apologize
but
to prioritize who gets what when
and again i'm thinking of shelburne um
now what is that process or is that
dynamic changed or is it uh by demand or
is it what up to the company's
discretion or how is that
priorities established for
unserved customers
priorities are determined by an analysis
of whether or not a given area is
financially feasible
right
this
changes that calculus in a way
that says
a lot more of these areas are now going
to be financially feasible
right because there's a there's a source
of federal funds
can be used to change the math
it's a lot harder if you're asking me
how do you decide which project to build
first
that is a lot more complicated and
probably it's beyond what i can answer
now okay
okay um thank you madam chair
i will say that
you know we're a relatively large
provider we're currently building
40 different projects in 40 different
towns
of varying sizes right now so it's
it's
not exactly it's not a linear
progression in the sense that you
put 100 percent of your effort into one
then you move on to the next and the
next the next so
okay thank you and i i'm thinking you
should move north but anyways thank you
[Laughter]
representative emrick thank you madam
chair i'll ask you the same question i
asked senator hennessey once once these
funds are invested and there's a build
out
and and you're the provider yes do you
take over those lines
to maintain them and own them so that
our expectation is that if we partner in
this program
we'll be contributing
whatever the non-federal matches so the
25 percent minimum match that'll be our
contribution with our private at-risk
capital
and then when the project is done we'll
own operate and be responsible for all
upgrades and maintenance for it the
statute um it's not on the bill but the
statute that passed last year actually
is very clear about that no grant
dollars can be used for maintenance it's
so that what that does hopefully is
enforce
some sustainability when companies are
looking at these projects
you don't want to invest this money
and then have
someone decide that it it can't sustain
itself
representative
mooning
thank you madam chair thank you for
testifying going back to that proposed
amendment by senator hennessey the line
a provider who successfully challenges
could we delete the words because
construction has commenced
and would that
improve for clarity so
to be clear um
senator as i understand it senator
hennessey's amendment only differs from
the bill that came over from the senate
but with the addition of the word
successfully
so it wouldn't be
it's not the only change to the bill is
the addition of the word successfully
um
i
i think our
advice would be not to
change
the bill further beyond adding
are there any further questions
representative lynn
thank you for taking my question up i
guess my question am i understanding
from
from the scheme of this that
if let's say let's say comcast
decides that it's going to build in
particular you know build out in some
particular area if if you make that
determination to do that and you get all
the regulatory approvals and all the
other things you need
do you get some
for lack of a better term some monopoly
protection in the sense that somebody
else is sort of prohibited from building
out we do not you don't get any
at any level either from the poc or the
municipality right so the the 1996
telecommunications act
which is a
successor to the 34 communications act
is very clear
about how it treats these issues there's
no
for a cable company there's no uh
exclusivity any permitting that we
receive from any community which there
was mention of a franchise it's called a
franchise in the industry they're not
exclusive state law similarly was
amended
in the late 90s following the 96 act say
there's no
marketplace constraint or any monopoly
authority inferred in any way at any
level
representative turcotte thank you madam
chair um could you say again how many
households are not served currently in
i believe
a reasonable estimate is between 25
and 30 000 households
call them locations
because
they may or may not be
year-round residences
but
call it 25 or 30 000
go ahead thank you um
and
based on maybe
past uh knowledge or
data out of those 25 to 30 000 how many
of those would actually
subscribe to service if offered yeah
so
uh penetration varies to some degree
based on socioeconomic factors but in
general uh in new hampshire
maybe 80
to a wired solution right i want to be i
want to make that i want to distinguish
in that way so
cell phone
penetration in the state is virtually
ubiquitous at this point it's
i think in the low 90s
but the market penetration for a wired
solution
is in the
nearly 80 percent
there's no reason to think that this
would be
different
for these areas yes representative thank
you you mentioned the socio
socioeconomic factors
most of the
underserved right now the 25 to 30 000
would that
mean that
a smaller percentage of those households
might
be interested in signing up or would
that still be 75 percent i think it's
there's not enough variation there to
change that top line number when you
look at the whole state so what we know
from a lot of great research that pew
has done in other
organizations is that adoption
is a larger problem than availability
and this bill fixes hopes seeks to fix
the availability issue right
make it act accessible to people if they
want it
the other issue here is adoption and
adoption is
a complicated set of issues has to do
with
you know cost of service access to
hardware it has to do with
uh demographic issues older populations
tend to adopt to a lesser degree than a
younger population it's it's a
multi-factored issue
the but
i don't see any reason to think that 80
percent high 70s
you know would not be the case across
thank you very much and um i will call
welcome
thank you good morning madam chair
members of the committee for the record
my name is michael akata i'm here on
behalf of the new hampshire electric
cooperative
just a little bit of background first
and foremost we are in support of the
bill
for those who aren't quite as familiar
with the co-op we are an electric
distribution company we serve 85 000
members across 118 communities
throughout new hampshire
with electric service
back in 2020
we formed a broadband subsidiary new
hampshire broadband to address a lot of
the issues that were discussed today for
our members to make sure that our
members our electric members had access
to high-quality reliable high-speed
internet service
that was a serious need that certainly
the pandemic helped to bring to the
surface in many ways
we've taken a number of steps to address
the issues of broadband
limited broadband access
we applied for and were successful in
getting cares funding in 2020.
with that funding we were able to
connect 1100 previously unserved
households and businesses in colebrook
stewart's town clarksville and leemster
we're currently expanding to provide
service to
the communities of acworth and sandwich
which will make
high-speed internet available to another
1800 uh
locations in those communities and we
just recently announced a major
expansion into grafton county that will
provide service to co-op members uh in
32 towns
and we estimate that's around uh 17 000
locations
so
a lot of activity and um certainly the
availability of uh federal funding and
support is critical for our efforts as
they were with cares uh mr hodgson
mentioned the art off auction that the
fcc ran we were a participant in that
and we did uh receive funding to build
out uh 70
census block areas throughout the state
with high-speed internet
so critical issue there's a lot of work
to be done
uh we are supportive of the bill and i
just want to highlight two critical
areas uh of support one is uh the
flexibility that the bill would provide
the bea to administer the funds uh there
is as was previously discussed by
senator hennessey a lot of federal
funding that is coming in through the
infrastructure and arpa
bills that were passed there is the
senate bill 85 process that this is
largely aimed at making um
changes to but flexibility on on how
those funds can be used and applied in
different ways so it's not a one size
fits all
and then the second is
flexibility on compliance with the
federal requirements of the different
funding opportunities so uh the arpa
fund
has sort of different rules to it than
the infrastructure fund and uh at the
very last page of the bill it provides
flexibility that the
federal guidance and the federal
requirements are sort of the prevailing
issues so if the state rules are in
conflict with the federal rules it gives
flexibility for the federal rules to um
to be utilized
with that i'd be happy to answer any
questions that the committee may have
some of us actually voted on that
to let the co-op
do broadband it it
makes so much sense that you already
have the polls
okay yes uh representative petrie oh
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question now are you
controlled by the puc
currently
so we are uh not rate regulated by the
public utilities commission so the puc
exists to balance the interest of
shareholders and customers
we're a non-profit we're owned by our
members so there isn't that balancing
there are certain areas where we are
still regulated by the puc energy
efficiency and sort of customer um
disconnections and payment arrangements
uh but by and large we are governed by
our uh democratically elected board of
directors thank you
by the way we like it that way
so thank you very much oh did you have a
question representative leishman sorry
no no problem madam chair thanks
so the previous uh
question i had concerning the build out
into areas that already had uh say
comcast service in those federal funds
that you obtained did you build into
areas that
already had service or was completely
unserviced
so they are unserved
most of the federal funding does not
allow
the federal funding that we have
previously
accessed so the cares funding as well as
the ardoff funding
it was specifically for areas identified
by the federal government through the
fcc maps that do not have service thanks
thanks venom chair
thank you very much are there any
further yes representative heath
thank you my question is um with regard
to
the social economic
group of people that are unable
financially to access
is there and i don't know very much
about all of this is there a priority
for you for comcast for
whomever um to make
some kind of um
scholarships or some kind of funding
available to those individuals i mean it
is costly i mean i know how much i pay a
month for my service and i'm sure that
there are many many families that can't
afford to pay what the cost is so how is
that handled and is that any part of the
federal requirements
so
yeah so i'll address that in two ways
the the first is yes affordability is a
part of the criteria that the federal
government has uh identified
specifically um
that needs to be weighed uh in addition
to making funding available for capital
construction
the federal government has also made a
affordability program available to help
offset the monthly cost of programs
as the electric co-op we're not for
profit
affordability is absolutely something
that is
critical and important to us and in the
center of of why we're doing this so you
know we talk about ensuring access
affordability and reliability
affordability is is a key area for us as
well and when we structure our broadband
plans um
we really do try to to keep that in mind
so uh in addition to
um
you know the federal funding uh making
sure we're we're operating essentially
yes representative walsh
just a quick question i know comcast has
a program that's i think ten dollars a
month for low income do you offer the
same program
we don't at this time but we are
actively
working on rolling out a uh exploring a
low income program and as i said there
is the federal affordability program
that
customers who would take advantage of
that would be paying essentially 10 a
are there any further questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you appreciate your testimony and
appreciate what the co-op does by the
way
okay
uh
i have no further
anyone signed up to testify
so i will close the hearing on
and open the hearing
on sb 402
relative to financial assistance for
municipalities affected by disasters
i said i did see senator khan here he
was hiding on me okay welcome we're
thank you madam chair it's a pleasure to
see
senate bill 402's genesis is
out of
two disasters that were declared
by
the president
that our department of homeland security
and emergency management
observed this last year
in cheshire and sullivan counties
these two disasters were the result of
significant rainfall that occurred in
two separate storms in july
and
impacted 21 different
towns in
cheshire and in cheshire county
this is a complicated process
working through fema
i'm still learning about it
and
but the impact on these towns 21 towns
uh
it was significant uh
waterways
don't know political boundaries uh the
most significant damage is in
towns outside of
my district i should have introduced
myself i'm j khan from keene represent
15 of 23 towns in cheshire county
but what was apparent here is that
uh
the storm affected a number of
communities and
how the state
participates in the process of recovery
uh ought to be a consistent approach not
by political
influence to have my project be superior
to your needs
but that the state have a consistent
approach
if one goes back and looks at history
from 2005 to 2007 when the series of
disasters were declared in cheshire
it was in the town of alstead and
probably people recalled the cold river
uh wiping out a bridge uh
carrying away uh
roadways
it was a significant disaster and i had
and it took years to settle this out uh
thank goodness the state participated
in the match process and so the match
process traditionally
is a 75 federal
uh
appropriation
through fema
in disaster recovery
25 percent
that requires a local match local match
could be from state or local funds
in that instance
with the alstead flood
the state
took several years to to understand what
the total cost of the projects and
recovery would be
and then matched the amounts
uh there's a legislative history on that
that dates to 2009
so that the floods that occurred in 2006
and 2007
where finally the state
covered the 25 match
uh that's what essentially is being
sought here
uh initially it was with the idea that
if it was 75 and a 25 percent local that
the local would be matched in two parts
12 and a half percent from the state
12 and a half percent from the
communities
and and why would that be necessary
some of these are small towns even if
it's a larger community like keene
these are not budgeted disasters and
nobody's carrying a surplus for a
disaster uh and
uh but
in the case of alstead uh if there was
uh 20 million dollars of damage for
instance uh 25 of that cost could you
know wipe out their budget
uh in any given year so
uh that's
uh probably the top end of of what this
disaster entails
uh
and then smaller amounts in a variety of
other communities that vary in size
but
cover communities like walpole and
keane and troy and winchester and
something that's happened in between
here is that the federal government has
uh notified our uh emergency management
department that
they will match this storm this incident
with a 90 10 match
so now we've got a 10 percent match
problem
and in my proposal to the senate uh it
was
uh how do we how do we quantify this so
i took stabs at trying to well i think
it'll cost this or i think it'll
the point is
there was no way to put a boundary on
the dollar amount
and so
i appreciate that president uh senate
proposed this amendment
and that's what you have in front of you
today
the way that i interpret the amendment
is that it is trying to provide a
shortcut process
for
the state to participate in the match
the
match is not determined by this language
but there is the intent for that match
to come forward
fema is currently in the process of
doing the evaluation on these in these
21 towns for
29 different applications
and uh
but the dollar amounts still aren't
known
and may not be known until the projects
here with us today is jen harper from
emergency management homeland security
and uh
she can get much further into the
details of how this is going to get
rustled to the ground
but the intent here is to provide a
shortcut process so that
these requests can come through the
governor to the fiscal committee
to the executive council and towns can
recoup the dollars
that
and restore stability to their local
treasuries
uh that's the intent
and i hope and i have to say this i hope
that we will
try to establish a fairness principle
that regardless of the dollar amount
regardless of the size of the town
that the towns who face disasters know
that the state is going to be there for
them to a certain extent
and we'll need to define that certain
extent whether that's fifty percent or a
hundred percent as it was in alstead
uh
what what that amount is
so i appreciate the committee uh
uh taking this under consideration and
glad to answer any questions
representative emerick
thank you madam chair uh senator
uh last week we heard uh uh
had a public hearing on senate bill 409
which is
is this complementary to that or
because i don't i haven't read all the
details of 409 but this seems to be the
same kind of thing
and thank you for bringing that up
409 establishes a
a ready loan
provision
so that
towns may not be able to wait the three
years
for fema approval
for contracts to be
to go through the purchasing process to
collect the receipts etc
it sets up an arrangement where through
the state's treasury there can be a zero
interest loan
to the town to complete the work
and and
solve the in immediate emergency that
the town faces
the town is
then on the hook
for repaying that amount to the state
treasury
as fema dollars would come in those
dollars would
pay down
the
debt obligation to the state treasurer
and
then
[Music]
this
would indicate will the state through
its
fund availability provide some match
to further pay down
like chairman
division one chair emerick i've been
trying to figure this out i've been
sitting here flipping back and forth
between the two bills
just trying to figure out how they play
on each other so under
the one we heard last week which is
409.
um they've got a payback they're
probably 12 percent the town does
under your bill this is it the idea the
state would pay that 12 so that the
local communities would be off the hook
for their share of what it cost to
yes let me clarify the
you're on you've got the right idea just
i'll try to tighten up on the numbers
in this instance fema has indicated that
they'll reimburse 90 percent
there's a ten percent town obligation so
if if
for instance
uh the town of alstead we'll just keep
using them uh i don't think
representative aarons will mind
that
if
they had
the
disaster and they wanted to
initiate the work immediately
they would go to the state treasury draw
down
they would they would
ask for a loan from the treasurer under
for five million dollars worth of work
they would complete that work
and probably along the way find out
from fema
that
they would reimburse
up to 4.5 million dollars depending on
is that what the total cost of the
project is
but let's just say the project cost and
the estimate and the drawdown were all
the
same amount
so 4.5 million dollars would ultimately
be paid or reimbursed to the town
that four and a half million dollars
would go directly from alstead to the
state treasury to pay down the 5 million
loan now we've got 500 000
hanging out there
of that 500 000
the intent of the original legislation
was that 50 percent of that two hundred
fifty thousand dollars would be paid by
the town in two hundred fifty thousand
dollars by the state
this language here doesn't indicate that
share
this language here says
but the state might pay the whole
hundred percent
so there's no share in here
uh
that was the original intent that i
brought forward
but
this doesn't clarify that
and and perhaps the committee would want
to do that on the other hand
uh precedent was set in 2009
reimbursing the alstead floods of 2007
uh at 100
of what the town's obligation was so
uh
but the state
the state as a participant in these
disasters and you know why is this
important to to try to wrestle in this
legislative legislative session because
and
having some
process and understanding in the towns
as to how
these emergencies are going to be
is is something that can come away from
are there any further
representative turcotte thank you madam
chair thanks for the question would it
be
would i be correct in simplifying the
difference between 409 and
uh this bill here that the difference is
one is a grant and one is a loan yes
representative lynn so i'm wondering um
is
we heard in connection with 409
that there's
that
the reason that that that needed to be
structured as loans is that if it wasn't
alone
the federal government would say that
that's
that um you know that's you've already
gotten this money and so i'm just kind
of wondering if this is a grant do we
have the same
problem that the federal government is
going to say well you're not eligible
for
whatever the amount of the government
i think that's a question for um
homeland security when and they're going
to testify here shortly so okay
that's that's fine sure you'll know
whether you might have had an answer if
you hold that question i would prefer
that sure okay homeland security answer
that that's fine
thank
you
representative edwards
uh thank you madam chair um
senator khan
do you imagine
if this bill were to pass that each
budget would have a direct appropriation
into some sort of a trust fund to be
ready to do this or or would this should
this be set up to just be a draw down on
any rainy day surplus how how would you
yeah
that that too might be a best question
to
homeland security uh emergency
management because uh
ultimately they need to be the
administrator uh of this and i would
envision that they would be the uh arm
of state government that would
bring those recommendations forward to
the governor uh
and and the process would then take off
from there and and hopefully they would
be aligned in some proximate time
so that
the legislature would see its full
exposure from a declared disaster
as opposed to seeing 21 separate
requests
are there any further questions for
senator khan
representative irv
thank you madam chair
thank you senator
could you just clarify for me
how this
limits
the amount the governor can draw to the
amount that fema is not picking up
because it seems to me to just being
open-ended the governor can
can uh approp to as authorized to draw
whatever money he wants for the
municipalities
i i agree that i don't see that this
puts a boundary on it except that it's
okay but you agree that that's not even
stated
yeah
thank you
okay are there further questions
seeing none thank you senator khan we're
always happy to have you here
thank you man
uh
thank you madam chair and good morning
finance committee for the record my name
is representative judy aaron i represent
sullivan county district 7 which is
acworth goshen langdon lobster and
washington
so i've been here before
and you've all heard my story so i'm not
going to repeat it again
and i did prepare some comments
um which
i'm not going to
uh read verbatim
um i just came here today
to ask that
you pass
this bill sb-402
it's an important bill and i think it's
got
um
it's much better than when it was
first proposed because it is
it has turned into
what i had hoped
would be
[Music]
the most useful
for our municipalities that
have incurred
damage from these natural disasters and
that is all along as i've been asking
the state and talking to various people
about the needs
of
my municipality acworth in particular
after the july 29 flood
and asking for some financial help for
our town
i was constantly being told that there's
no statutory mechanism to get money to
towns
who are in need
and this bill does that
because it's it's fairly open-ended it
is a grant
from the state to help a town
the problem that we're having
as we're wrestling with sb 402 sb 409
and even the bill that i proposed in the
house which would have set up a
municipal disaster relief fund at the
state level
the problems that we've run into with
this is that
if it's not alone
reimbursement from fema that they
wouldn't give you the amount of money
that you need
to
counter
sort of put on the side with also the
issue of towns needing to do work
right away
after a disaster happens in order to get
them back online and make streets safe
and make
roads passable for emts and emergency
vehicles and so forth
so we have this situation where
towns need help immediately or even
later on after
fema does reimburse funds but don't
doesn't reimburse the entire amount or
maybe doesn't reimburse them at all
because maybe there's a problem with the
way in which the product project was
done in the first place
the town needs money
they could use it in the form of a grant
or
the town could take a loan and
pay somehow figure out how to pay that
back in the end
the problem is that towns are dealing
with the bureaucracy of a federal
government
where
you submit a project
to fema
for reimbursement
the town has to lay out that money first
in the beginning to do the project
and then the reimbursement comes later
from fema if the project is approved
and if fema decides fema decides how
much they're going to reimburse or not
uh represent aaron could you please
stick to the topic yet so so
the topic is that this particular bill
allows for monies to be given to
towns that need it
either in the beginning
of the process where they might need
funds immediately
or later on
after the project is finished
and money has come back from fema but
not the entire amount so that the town
can still
have access to some funds from the state
this bill allows for a statutory
mechanism for the state to give money to
a town that needs it after a natural
disaster
and
i you know i think that that that's an
important
um
an important aspect
is
the town needs the the the state really
should have a mechanism whereby they can
help the towns in the in these
situations
thank you very much are there uh
questions
all right seeing none thank you very
much um
i will call on uh
from the homeland
good morning thank you my name is
jennifer harper i'm the director for
homeland security and emergency
management within the department of
safety and with me is vanessa yurango
she is the program manager for our
disaster recovery program at the state
and knows the fema guidance inside and
out you may have remembered fallon reed
sitting next to me previously fallon
just had a baby yesterday so oh
yes yes it's all good baby boy is here
oh everybody's happy and healthy but uh
so vanessa is gonna be my sidekick uh
for a while
um so
please be assured that she can answer
the questions that fallon was answering
just as eloquently
i guess
questions at this point
that people may have or
did you have anything you wanted to say
no and i just
okay that's fine no no okay yeah now
represent lynn you may ask your question
so the the question it's really the same
question that i asked for senator khan
is if this
if this bill as opposed to 409 is a this
bill is a grant whereas 409 was talking
about alone
is there some danger
that
if money is is distributed to a
municipality under the authority that
would be granted by this bill
that fema would then say well you have
the municipality has no obligation to
pay it back
so that
that's not you know it we can't
we can't reimburse you federal money
uh for
uh for this
grant so let me start and then
this
would be a grant at the end of the
project
period i think
there may be some discussion that needs
to happen in a work session or something
but
as senator khan was mentioning um
the communities would get reimbursed
from fema for a project so let's just
say
the town of jen had a disaster and their
25 streets were just were
damaged
the town of jen works with vanessa's
group and fema they write up the
projects for the 25 roads
and submit them
as they're
worked on so there's two pieces
there's a small project and a large
project small projects are up to
depends on the disaster but it's around
three grand and change so three thousand
dollars so if it's a small little area
three thousand dollars fema will will
obligate the money give the money to the
community fix the road have a nice day
if it cost them twenty five hundred
dollars they get to keep the five
hundred dollars
oh yeah please clarify this is why she's
here
thank you um so sorry to clarify fema
has multiple different lanes of projects
there are small projects and large
projects the small project and large
project thresholds change on a annual
basis based on the federal government
every federal fiscal year so the small
project threshold is the minimum a
project must be in order to be eligible
for fema and that hovers around three
grand every year the large project
threshold hovers around 130 grand each
year so if it is 130 grand or over it's
considered a large project and it's
reimbursed to the penny for eligible
work small projects that fall between
the 3 grand and 130 grand
variable numbers
are considered small projects those can
be reimbursed if the work is done or if
the work needs to be completed
in time
so they can be completed on actuals or
on an estimate if the um for example if
it's done on an estimate and the
community comes in under budget they can
keep the remaining money and do whatever
they want with it if it comes in over
bonded budget then that's the risk that
they take on in doing a small project so
that's the difference between the two
yeah so i guess where i was going was
for those larger small projects are sort
of easy those larger projects
in chatting with senator khan and
representative aaron um
it could take
years for 25 roads to be fixed
and
where does this come in so fema would
say two years from now they finish main
street in the town of jen and they
submit all their receipts they get
reimbursed a hundred thousand dollars
and fema would pay ninety percent of
that that ten percent is what this would
cover so the hundred thousand dollars
the town of gen could come to the
governor and say hey
we don't have the money to cover this 10
percent can we get a grant from the
state to cover the hundred thousand
dollars because our town can't absorb
that 10
so that would be where this would be a
grant and that's fine because fema's
already paid the 90
so i think a grant in this case
works
right yep um
so i will say um it's a good question
about duplication and benefits i believe
that's where your question stems from
correct
um and so it's definitely something to
consider um i think that
with regard to
this being the 10 that fema's not
covering
um
it may be worth looking at the language
just to ensure that there's no way that
fema could consider this to be a
duplication of benefits meaning if we
were to potentially consider
or somebody were to
excuse me potentially consider adding
language such as this money where we
would excuse me would be used for
the non-federal share or for things that
were not eligible under federal funding
so for example the non-federal share
match which is what the town contributes
to 10 is not eligible for fema
reimbursement therefore it could not be
a duplication of benefits additionally
work that was not eligible under fema's
program could also not be a duplication
of benefits
thank you
you look like you have a follow-up well
no i'm just wondering i mean do you
you don't happen to have any sort of
suggested language that you think might
except perhaps
sorry except perhaps to say
perhaps something like
this funding could be used on things
that are not eligible for on items that
are not eligible for federal
reimbursement
something broad that could cover both
categories including non-federal match
and things that are deemed not eligible
under fema's programs
okay
thank you
are there further questions
oh my heavens
representative hatch i'll go around this
way
go ahead
oh you didn't have your hand up i did
but he was handed up first
all right
representative leitchman thank you madam
chair and thanks representative hatch
so
i'm a little curious you didn't take a
position on the bill
or didn't provide any testimony so
am i to assume and i never like to
assume that
you're not comfortable with the bill
unless there's new language to try to
clear up
perhaps some
double funding that this might create or
um
i
so i'm not opposed to this i just want
to make sure that
everybody's on the same page and
understands the interpretation of it so
that's that's my only hesitancy so i
knew i didn't know but i figured that
there would be a number of questions
that would come up today
so
you're correct in saying that i did not
take a stand on it
i didn't want to take a stand on it
and then have a bunch of questions come
up and me looking like a deer in the
headlight going oh we hadn't thought
about that so
um
i appreciate the questions that
representative lin had and some of the
questions that you all asked
representative khan because vanessa and
i were both copiously taking notes and
you know i think it's really important
that we get this right the first time so
that when
if a town if this passes then a town
submits
for 10
that they
are
clearly know the expectation of what
they're going to get or what they're not
going to get
thanks
thank you madam chair
representative patch thank you madam
chair
in addition to that but the statement
that needs to be added to this bill for
clarity um stating that for items not
my thoughts are
there's a disaster a town needs money
immediately and i'm not so sure
the needs are delineated between what's
a federal
um approved grant would be approved
under a federal grant and what is it so
how would that work just
if you do you follow my question i'm not
sure i'm clear on that if and thank you
madam chair okay
um i think if i have followed today
correctly and the intent of the bill
that the intent of the bill is to cover
the portion of the expense that fema
will not cover which is likely to be
things that are ineligible or
potentially um up to the 10 match for
these two disasters that occurred in
2021 in cheshire and sullivan counties
is that correct yeah okay
so i think in that case um
you know we have two bills that are at
work here 409 and 402. it sounds like
409 is the one that's intended to be the
one that's more expeditious of the two
provides that immediate relief as the
name suggests expedited
loan whereas this is to come in and help
make the community whole after fema's
reimbursement has kicked in
yeah
i just wanted to be clear thank you
madam chair and thank you
thank you madam chair um is there any
way that fema could try and if if we pay
the 10 federal match out of state funds
does fema have a mechanism to try and
claw back that money then
do they have that would they do they do
audits or something where they might
come back and try and claim that money
or claim that
that you know the town wasn't
doing this in good faith
if i understand your question correctly
correct me if i'm wrong but they've
already said that a town were paying the
90 of eligible expenses what they are
not paying
is things that are ineligible already
so yes they do audits but
we're paying that 10
the state is
going to pay that 10 to the community in
the form of a grant fema's not correct
me if i'm wrong it's going to be able to
it's not federal money it would be state
money that's paying the town so fema
can't come back and say hey
you did something wrong when they
already made a determination that
they're paying 90 percent of fixing main
street
i guess follow-up
yes please my concern comes from
my lack of knowing federal fema law and
that is
does the federal law say that the local
community has to pay that 10
or is it just not fema pays the 10
percent it's not fema that pays the 10
percent they don't care the federal
government says have a nice day we're
paying you 90
here it is
what how they get that 10
if they get that 10
they can either do it themselves as the
town or the state can pay it or
you know i guess a pr a private entity
could pay it but it's not it can't come
from other federal grant
monies
that alleviates my concern thank you
okay
representative edwards
uh thank thank you madam chair um
under the assumption that this bill
passes just to set the context
uh
we're 12 months away from having this do
our next two year budget
how much would you request in the budget
for this in each of those two years and
and assuming you don't know that answer
could you describe the methodology that
you might use to come upon a budget
number
so i think that was the original issue
with this that
the collective we
could not come up with a number to put
in the budget which is how we got to
this language if i'm not mistaken
yes senator khan is shaking his head yes
so we
all the smart people
including
vanessa and fallon
um
there's no way to know for cheshire and
sullivan county what that 10 percent is
going to be six years from now
to be able to put in to the 2425 budget
that
10 million or 2 million or
50 million
which is why we did this now it would be
the community would come after the main
street project was done two years later
alstead comes to the table and says hey
we got our 90 percent from fema the
project is closed out we need a million
follow it uh all right i i think i
understand that um
so
the need is expressed by representative
aaron is uh fast cash now
they that the towns need the money right
away what you've described is a a look
back process once we know what fema's
gonna reimburse and all
um so there seems to be a difference in
purposes there that
i i'd like to understand a little bit
better
um what
how how do we how do we meet
representative aaron's stated need
under this law i'm not seeing any
language even in here to talk about the
timing of when the payments are made
it's it's absent whether or not it's up
front or after the fact so we at least
would need to clarify that in the
language i think
uh thank you i think that
based on what we've heard from
representative aaron you know there are
kind of two needs that these communities
have you know the first is definitely as
you said fast cash now um to help
alleviate the immediate burden but the
other half of this conversation is the
long-term needs of these communities and
their economic viability so
being able to make them whole at the end
is going to put them in a position where
you know they are ready for that next
disaster or can at least keep their
current budgets running so i think
that's why there are two different bills
at play here
with regard to the timing of
reimbursement um that's definitely still
a discussion that's open you know we
were trying to decide do we do this on a
project by project basis do we wait
until the end of the disaster um that
would still have to be sorted out
but there's some flexibility there
if that makes sense
are there further questions
yes
represent murray
thank you madam chair can we go back to
what eligible and non-eligible means
fema will cover ninety percent of
eligible projects
um a hundred ninety percent of one
hundred percent eligible projects when
you were saying well this other money
could be used for ill uneligible
non-eligible ineligible ineligible
projects um
there's a conflict here that i don't
understand is it's not fema doesn't
cover 90 percent of eligible and
illegible
ineligible projects all at the same time
those are two different things so it
doesn't seem to me or it could it seems
to me that there would be a project a
problem to say well the
ineligible projects could be used for
this other 10 because it's that 10
percent is based on 100 percent eligible
projects
so can you address just there there's a
conflict here i don't understand that i
think we would need to understand if we
need to straighten out this language
to make clear
that this 10
isn't impacted and doesn't come back to
bite the communities afterwards does
that make sense the difference between
the two words i think so yeah so i think
the easiest way
and keeping in mind that fema's public
assistance program is
has so much depth there's a lot to it
but if you look at it holistically
expenses that a community has
post-disaster are kind of divided into
two parts those that are eligible under
fema pa and those that are not eligible
or are ineligible under pa
so in this case 100 of expenses that are
deemed eligible in fema's program of
that 100 percent 90 would be reimbursed
by fema for these disasters and the
other 10 would hopefully be covered by
this bill anything that is ineligible
consider it a completely separate number
that's not tied to the 10 percent that
we're discussing today
does that help
yeah if i could
let me just try to give a very simple
example
um
let's say the main street is the problem
okay
and then you have a feeder street in
that wasn't damaged but you think that
you need to fix
the culvert on the feeder street
okay
well fema doesn't think you need to fix
that
and so that
if you fixed it it would be ineligible
okay
but
i think that's
kind of the easiest way to try to
explain some of that ineligible stuff
that we'll talk about this afternoon i
could we wouldn't be able to include
that or that that would not be able to
be included in the ten percent that's
correct
that's correct
okay are there
representative lin
yes i i guess the one question i have is
sort of a follow-up to representative
edward's question is this if if it it
seems like what we're talking about is
that
monies that would be dispersed by
the governor under this bill would not
be happening quickly it would be sort of
at the end of the process
and so if it's at the end of the process
and you were you were both using the
term two years as an example but even if
it was only one year
i guess i'm just wondering what
why
why is it
why does it make sense to allow that
decision to be made by the governor the
executive council and the fiscal
committee only as opposed to the full
legislature when presumably even if it
was a year or or certainly if it was two
years the legislature would be back in
session and could have then the full
legislature could approach could
consider the matter and appropriate the
money
man i think i can speak to the program
okay
um
so programmatically speaking for fema's
pa process there are multiple points in
its decision-making process where things
might be determined to be ineligible for
example so we've kind of been talking
about two different
things that this bill could fund
ineligible expenses and the 10
the ineligible expenses are likely to
fall out of that process sooner so
that's kind of on a rolling basis and
that could happen at any time within the
process but likely a lot of them are
identified closer to the beginning of
the process and fewer as you move on
um and the reasons for ineligibility can
vary it could just be the facility but
it could also be as representative
aarons noted
you know the way that the process was
done maybe a community didn't follow all
of the rules within fema's program for
example and that could lead to
ineligibility down the line but that's
kind of a rolling basis the other part
of what this bill would fund which is
the 10
is determined more at the end of the
process it will be sooner for small
projects and a longer process for large
projects due to their relative
complexities within the program does
that help answer your question
yes thank
you are there any further questions
we're looking forward to seeing you this
afternoon
we shall be here i knew it
oh
is there anyone that signed in on the
uh margaret burns from nhma is in favor
of this other than that the other
folks have testified so
thank you very much and as a result
we will close the hearing on hb 402
and open the hearing on sb
making an appropriation to the
department of health and human services
for nursing home reimbursement rates
oh i'm here i was i was looking for you
back in the corner sorry i was hiding in
thank you madam chair for the record
cindy rosenwald from senate district 13
nashua
and i'm pleased to introduce senate bill
412 which will correct an inadvertent
error
that was made last spring when the
legislature increased nursing home rates
by 5
in house bill 2.
this was necessary as nursing homes have
seen costs increase
but have not been able to operate at
full capacity since the start of the
pandemic
the department was directed in house
bill 2 to raise rates by 5 percent
starting july 1st
and as you know nursing home rate
setting is complex
it depends on the number of patients and
their acuity
the inadvertent error was caused by
another house bill 2 provision
that required reimbursement to be
calculated over a higher bed census
than has been the reality
recently during the pandemic
as a result the budgeted appropriation
for that five percent rate increase was
only enough
for the department to raise rates last
summer by um
an average of just over one percent
they were able to make
a second adjustment in october
to about three and a half percent going
forward and again in january to
fulfill our promised five percent
increase however
the appropriation in house bill 2
might not be enough to backfill the
first half of the current fiscal year
or sustain the increase through the
biennium
so we worked with
the department and lba on language for a
contingent five million dollar
appropriation in case the budget is not
adequate to fulfill our commitment to
the nursing homes
if it's not needed it will lapse at the
end of the biennium
i want to note also that this rate
increase will not increase cost to the
counties
and um
i think that's important
i hope you'll all agree with me that the
legislature keeps its promise and passed
edwards
uh thank you madam chair um
thank you for taking the question
senator rosenwald
um
so i i was part of the process where we
wanted to add the five percent uh
beginning on july one
so i'm i'm so what i'm going to ask you
is really going to sound like i'm
opposed to that but i just i just want
to make sure i understand some logic
here
uh our logic when we assigned the five
percent was that the rates were so low
that they were having trouble paying the
payroll necessary to attract personnel
so we wanted to give them a bump
so that they could afford better wages
and hopefully
cut down on some of their vacancies that
that's why we did it
but now that this bill is coming forward
it's it's making it retroactive to july
one to keep the promises
but
it's no longer
in a able to be timed to influence the
salaries and the hiring and it is so
it's sort of like the cow has already
gotten out of the barn the damage has
already been done
and that what we maybe ought to be doing
is instead of making retroactive to july
pick a date in the very near future and
so what
so what do you think what do you think
about what i just said what what is the
underlying rationale at
this point given that there was a mess
up why
why should we go retroactive to july 1
since it's not going to hire anyone last
august
thank you for the question i i think
the problem was
bigger than only the ability to recruit
and retain staff
i think the nursing homes
also had higher costs
for
ppe
testing other kinds of supplies
so i don't think it was only about staff
but
um i would just reiterate we made a
promise
that this would happen july 1st and and
i think
we
are nothing if if you can't rely on our
word
what do we really
follow-up
i i i agree
in the with the concept of credibility
and keeping the word i i just am looking
at the three letters of support that we
receive from the new hampshire
association of counties
the alzheimer's association
and the um and then a individual haley
derosas
and all of them really cite that the
that the money is needed to
improve salaries and hire people so
so
so while there may be ppe issues it's it
isn't being discussed in any of the
testimony we've gotten so far so i guess
you're introducing it now well i
haven't seen those letters
um
but
i'd also say that the the fact that the
nursing homes have not been operated
able to operate at full capacity
has
has an effect beyond the nursing homes
because it has meant that
hospitals have had to keep patients
beyond their
need for hospitalization
and that has resulted
at various times over the last year
in a lack of available hospital beds in
our communities and a necessity to send
patients out of the communities and
sometimes out of state so
i think we have to
look at
our health care system really as a
system
and the
we should be operating
all levels of care at capacity to the
extent that we can because
they have impacts
are there further questions
uh i i do have a question and it may be
better to ask
the counties but
my question deals with
the
workers
if we don't have the people
available to fill the jobs
we can't fill the nursing home
and we have
in fiscal
given money
to help with
the
um
the hospitalization so they can move
more quickly to the nursing home
but am i hearing you say that
the problem is staffing at the nursing
homes
that's causing the problem
or is it
not the staffing but something else i
think staffing has been
a big issue at nursing homes
for
a number of years but it's been
we've had to for example
nursing homes couldn't have
um
two patients per room
i mean we've had a lot of capacity
problems but a lot of it is staffing
and
um
we're not able
to
require
that
funds be directly passed through
to increase wages for staff medicaid
regulations don't allow that
but there are other ways and we have
heard
from the nursing homes that their
intention is to
increase compensation for staff of
course we have to fight with
out of state
facilities that
tend to to pay more
thank you are there any further
questions for senator rosenwald
representative hatch
thank you madam sheriff i mean just for
my clarity i guess it's not just the
cost of staffing and other materials but
also um it's a confluence of uh items
where nursing homes were hit from all
ends for example reimbursement you just
met uh mentioned that there's a little
uh shortfall
reimbursement because only one patient
per room isn't so it's it's not just
tapping it's a
plethora of fish anywhere a nursing home
has expenses they were impacted and on
top of that the reimbursement structure
was interrupted as that
i think it is i think it's a complex
situation that is not only staffing but
also infection control practices
and um supplies but i believe they're
here
and
they can thank you explain it better all
set thank you
are there any other questions uh
representing edwards
so this may not be for senator rosenwald
but is there's
somebody from the department who's going
to uh testify to us today and if they're
not here now can they be here for when
division three goes over this this
afternoon
is there somebody from the department
ready to talk about this
i i do have some questions for you all
right well when i get a pink card she
can come up
okay thank you yeah just just one last
question
from me
this applies to
not only county nursing homes but
private nursing homes
uh for-profit nursing homes whatever
it does because it's a medicaid
reimbursement rate
and um
in some parts of the state more than
others
private nursing homes
have
residents who are on medicaid so it's
not just the counties
i thought that was right but wanted to
absolutely make sure
okay thank you thank you appreciate uh
your patience with us for being late it
got me out of ways and me and so i was
happy oh thank you
i won't mention that okay
all right
um
jim monahan
yeah new hampshire association of
counties
great uh good morning um madam chairman
i'm jim monahan with the dupont group we
represent the new hampshire association
of counties
uh and i'm here to support senate bill
412. i think senator rosenwald um
in
the exchange representative edwards
captured uh what we're trying to address
here which was there at in the budget
process last year there seemed to be a
good bipartisan house senate agreement
to try to do a five percent rate
increase for
all nursing homes uh and
uh
as has been articulated
providing adequate general funds to make
that work um uh needs to be corrected
and so we're here to support that um i
can
certainly get into details if you want
but uh the funding for this uh is not
um a county expense because of
provisions that
uh the uh the budget
built in last year including the the
county cap
which doesn't change as a consequence of
this rate increase as well as for the
new cascade of funds which is
articulated in house bill 2
that cascade of funds changed so that it
would when it comes to funding a rate
increase like this it would be federal
money medicaid money first uh the
general general fund credit
then the general fund and then the
counties so that combination of the
cascade of dollars as well as the county
cap ensure that
this is not a new expense on the
counties
i'm also happy to answer
any questions about the the mechanics
of this but um i think brooke is
probably in a better position to answer
how
uh the accounting at dhhs um is playing
out in this
and i'm sorry also i'm sure he's about
to ask me or i can about the issue
around staffing i can address that as
uh thank you madam chair um
so uh mr moynihan uh this this letter
that's from the association a county
signed by wendy piper this this is are
you able to talk to this
letter is this is this dated april 11th
yes sir and i have copies for the
committee okay so um there's in the
second paragraph uh towards the right
it's it begins to say that the daily
rate should be no less than 105 percent
of the average daily rate in effect
no no less to me implies that it could
be more
uh is is there any intent that it's it's
more than the five percent that we
talked about
in the budget cycle
is that a poor choice of wording should
it just be
105 period
i mean if you if you want to increase it
more i don't think the county nursing
homes would object
um but that's the i believe that was the
language that was included in house bill
2 and that's why it's re-articulated in
412.
okay and then uh with regard to the
question around you know do we
it's a retroactive
uh provision i can speak at least for
the counties and as you all know if you
go to your account delegation meetings
you're on the
county nursing home budgets they
the expectation was this rate increase
would happen and so they plan the
budgets accordingly including uh
staffing budgets so
if the depending on the nursing home uh
in the county there's certainly the risk
that if the rate increase
doesn't happen there'd be you know to
meet your budget you might have to reach
into the county funds as you all know
the county subsidize those budgets
anyway
um so
representative edwards raised the
question about the retroactive increase
on staffing costs i believe the counties
would find a way within the budgets to
ensure that those
funds are used to cover their staffing
budgets
excuse me no not all right i'm just
trying i'm just
trying to think about the county budgets
um
okay
so if your county assumed that they were
going to have the five 5 rate increase
and it doesn't come then there's a risk
they would have to adjust the nursing
home budget downward
that's something to consider
the other consideration is though that
while
uh
the the counties do pay the non-federal
share of medicaid
this is constructed in a way that the
this
rate increase would not require
uh that the counties match the federal
funds
so
um
[Music]
i think
most counties have finished their budget
maybe they haven't but we have
in carroll county and i have i have no
idea what
percent we we looked at but
um
i guess that from that
perspective
what representative edwards said about
not being retroactive
makes sense to me but i'll let you tell
me why yeah it doesn't make sense to you
some of the counties have calendar
budgets and some of the counties have
fiscal year budgets so i guess my
observation had more to do with the
county those counties are on the on the
okay okay uh representative
so am i understanding to follow up on
representative edward's question about
the not less than language so if i'm
understanding if we if we if this bill
is approved
it would be
authorization to allow
uh an increase above five percent and in
fact to use the five million dollars to
we would have appropriated five million
dollars to
well i guess i'll make an observation
but at the end of the day it's probably
better that you get direction from the
department of health and human services
on that um as i said the authorization
to
increase rates up to to no less than 105
percent was included in the in the
budget
um so i believe what uh this legislation
is doing is just ensuring that it's an
adequate appropriation to meet that
obligation
okay
thank you okay are there any further
quote yes for uh representative leishman
thank you madam cheers
so i guess i have a concern on the
retroactive portion of this
we've heard about staffing issues how
does that affect going backwards help
um
by last year you mean
well the bills prior to june 30th or
after june or or after july 4 says going
backwards to be retroactive so i'm
curious how bad representative leishman
please talk into your mic because as we
know people are listening out there
thank you thanks madam chair
so i'm concerned again with the language
retroactive and we've talked about
staffing issues today
how would going back
help us with staffing issues
wouldn't it be better going forward to
address staffing issues and use the five
million dollars going forward
to help
better pay staff and provide other
financials yeah let me i'll try to get
some clarity before i come back at three
o'clock for division three on this um so
i think that and again i think we want
to hear from the department around the
mechanics of how how it flows you know
um
uh and and the answer i'll try to get
through representative leashman is in
the at least for the the counties how
have they uh how would they account for
not having the 105 having the five
percent rate increase
um
and how they have accounted how they it
may well be that the budgets include the
expectation of that
uh and so they're funding
the staffing with the expectation that
it'll eventually catch up with them
okay
i have great faith in division three
madam chairs so i'm sure they'll take
care of it thanks
so do i are there any further questions
okay seeing none
i have rosemary
is it's
seminole
and she represents the golden view
healthcare center in meredith
which i drive by every single day thank
you madam chair
yes so i've been a licensed nursing home
administrator in the state of new
hampshire for over 25 years and i've
been at golden view which is an
independent nonprofit private facility
for over 20 years
and i fully support the bill as it's
written
and
i just wanted to shed some light we
talked a lot about staffing issues
so one of the questions i think um
representative edwards is how is this
retroactive
why is that going to help us now
so
you know we thought we were getting that
five percent money um we
budgeted staff increases based on that
promise
we
first quarter have lost 138 000
so getting the money now
will help to mitigate those losses going
forward
so that i hope helps them shed a light
on that
i also wanted to talk about it's not
just staffing
staffing is a huge problem
golden view has two units closed
now i'm in available so they have to go
sometimes to nashua or even out of state
to get the care that they need
but we also have issues with food
supplies and utilities
and this is not including pandemic
supplies we've taken out infection
control ppe out of this
just the cost of utilities have gone up
20 percent
the cost of
food and supplies are up about two
dollars and fifty cents per patient per
day
um so we are in a serious crisis not
just staffing but all these other um
issues that are before us and i would
like to just you know yes the
reimbursement is extremely complicated
but as a brief statement
our reimbursement rates are set on
historical costs
um the january uh rate setting was based
on 2019 costs
and the july rate setting was based on
2018 costs
so they're not even
currently reimbursed on our current
costs of what we're facing today
on top of that we have that wonderful
budget neutrality factor
which was 22 percent and 25
so currently we're at
increased costs of about 15 percent
overall
to care for a person
yet we're reimbursed on historical cost
would then reduce further by the budget
neutrality factor
so we're out of the gate today at a loss
of 45 percent
that's that's the reality that's where
we're at
we do have a demand for our services
we can't meet that demand because we
can't get staff
um not only are the staffing costs
astronomically rising
it's also the other things i mentioned
the food the utilities and just general
supplies
so this money going retroactively is
going to help
mitigate extreme losses
for our facility and i know i'm not the
only provider
and i did want to mention um
somebody had mentioned earlier about
what it means when a facility closes or
when they have
closed units it's not just affecting the
healthcare continuum
as a community nonprofit we
provide many opportunities for the
schools to have their clinical rotation
at our facility
so it's affecting the local colleges
it affects integrated intergenerational
program elementary school kids coming
we provide education for the community
free
so it it's not just the health care
continuum we're looking at the impact is
greater than that on on the citizenship
of of new hampshire and the only other
final thing um
i wanted to say is um
about
um the staff and i um
i think the staff are real heroes that
continue to work in in nursing homes
i really do um not me but the direct
care staff
it's not just nursing that's affected
it's dining services it's all the things
that have to go into the care of an
thank you
aspect of
someone that is actually operating a
nursing home so thank you representative
weiler you have a question
thank you madam chair have him get
involved with a couple of nursing homes
i'm told that uh some of them
excuse me
restrict the amount of medicaid patients
because it's unaffordable
what's the percentage of medicaid
patients in your nursing home um we
average about 80 percent medicaid 80
yeah and that's a private unusual thank
are there any further questions
seeing none thank you very much i really
appreciate you coming down and
if there's any opportunity for you to
stay for the three o'clock
work session i think that that would be
helpful
uh
i have mr brandon williams
from new hampshire healthcare
association
uh
excuse me
kevin would you take care of handing
thank you very much
thank you madam chair and honorable
members of the committee for the record
my name is brendan williams i'm the
president of the new hampshire
healthcare association
uh we represent most of the state's
private nursing homes jointly represent
one county facility
also represent the cedar crest center
for children with disabilities and a
number of assisted living facilities
we strongly commend to you
this bill
again this bill
addresses a
oversight that was made in the budgeting
process
last legislative session it was intended
that there be a five percent increase in
fact we heralded legislators for having
provided
that increase and just regrettably
mechanically it did not happen
we went to work immediately
with the department and with sympathetic
lawmakers
to try to rectify this issue and um
our members have known since last summer
that a fix was on its way
and would be proposed in the senate and
of course as you know has passed the
senate unanimously
uh
with respect to representative edwards's
uh question
uh facilities are not going to enjoy
some sort of retroactive
surfeit if this money were to be
appropriated
but they will use it to staunch
their ongoing losses
in the provision of care
i've included in my uh testimony a
letter from
uh catholic charities which is my
biggest non-profit
nursing home provider
they're projecting a loss for this
fiscal year of one and a half million
dollars
in their operations
they're not going to be able to operate
uh very much longer
with those sorts of losses and this is
an organization that has been providing
nursing home care in our state
since 1948.
i think the same is true of a lot of uh
independent uh providers uh that i
represent uh family-owned facilities
uh non-profits uh proprietary nonprofit
alike
uh everybody is at the edge of a
precipice here
the nationally we've seen a loss of over
400 000 staff
for residential care facilities and
nursing homes the bureau of labor
statistics slumps those two things
together
we actually saw
an even greater loss a continued loss
in february and march under their
projections
if you can't staff you can't build
occupancy if you can't staff you can't
even maintain
the care
for the residents that you do have
and things become very precarious indeed
i've included data from a national
organization
that shows that new hampshire has the
nation's seventh worst
staffing crisis but if you look at that
list
we're not really far away from number
one it's just a matter of percentages at
this point
we just simply can't find the people and
uh you know all of us are familiar with
the concept of the great resignation
that occurred
uh as a result of the pandemic and
people sort of rethinking what sort of
work they wanted to get into
and uh you know a lot of opportunities
have arisen uh for folks and we've seen
wage increases in the service economy um
and one has to ask oneself
uh if you're working for a nursing home
uh why not just go down the street and
work for walmart for more money
or for some fast food uh
franchise and make more money
because you will
if you're working in the kitchen and
dietary department you definitely will
because our ability to pay is
constrained by medicaid reimbursement
i quote in a letter that i submitted to
you
my colleague from kentucky
who sort of makes the analogy between a
nursing home and chick-fil-a
if chick-fil-a has increased costs they
can pass those costs along to the
customer
for us government's the customer we
can't pass those costs along
and when you hear goldenview say that 80
percent of their residents are on
medicaid
in response to representative weiler's
question
under federal law if you have a medicaid
contract you can't restrict entry uh
based on ability to pay so it's first
come first serve
and so if you've got a a medicaid person
uh who's uh applying to go into your
facility
at the same time that a private payer is
it's whoever got first in line
and chances are you can't admit either
at this point just simply because uh
facilities uh can't staff to build their
occupancy
uh when you look at the fact that we
have uh an average occupancy of 77
percent right now we were as high as
86 percent uh before the pandemic
that's a recipe for disaster
this is an extinction event facilities
are not going to be able to continue to
operate
if they cannot fill those beds
and i include the examples of some other
states and what they've done on on april
7th
the new hampshire excuse me the nebraska
unicameral
overrode the governor's veto and gave
nursing homes a 15 percent rate increase
and that's after the governor himself
had given them a 20 a day rate increase
you see examples in any number of states
whether they be
republican states or democratic states
of legislatures
rushing to the fore uh because this is a
crisis uh throughout the entire country
right now
and uh we have been very grateful uh for
the cares act funds that have been
allocated to us uh by uh governor sununu
uh by the executive council
by the joint fiscal committee
but we're going to need additional
assistance uh even this five percent
rate increase is but a drop in the
bucket
uh compared to
where we are at right now uh we are
bleeding
and this will not staunch that bleeding
you will see closures of nursing homes
throughout the state
and
when a nursing home closes vulnerable
people are displaced and they're no
longer cared for in their community
they're displaced far away in many cases
and
staff lose their jobs
and in some communities those nursing
homes are among your largest employers
so
it's a desperate situation and we really
thank you for considering this bill
because again
it would effectuate what it is that you
intended to do
what it is that
providers relied upon
in knowing that this legislature was
trying to do the right thing
effective last july 1st and
so
every aspect of this bill is commendable
if anything we would wish it to be
increased
and we we thank you very much for your
consideration i'm happy to
very happy to take any questions
are there any questions
representative edwards uh thank you
madam chair so um
very compelling testimony thank you a
lot of good information in there i i
i
am trying to
parse together
a couple of things you said that we're
facing sort of an existential threat
with our nursing home
continuity
and that we have a a long-term
employer employment problem
and if we got a long-term employment
problem
and we we can throw we can we can
certainly spend this five percent
but
how how how does that
stop or halt
the existential threat that you're
referring to when we're still confronted
with a long-term problem
this bill may be necessary but it's not
sufficient where what what must we do
to really address this
thank you for your question
representative i have to have the
humility to say i'm not sure uh
certainly this bill uh isn't enough in
terms of what it would do you're right
this is a long-term crisis right now
facilities are resorting to out-of-state
staffing agencies in order to just
simply maintain staffing
those agencies have increased their
prices to the point where you might be
paying 50 an hour for a licensed nursing
assistant uh once these out-of-state
agencies enter your facility they start
hiring away your own staff
uh where whereupon you're then paying
the agency for your own staff to work
for you and uh it really feels like
we're swirling down the drain uh you
know i think something like
the examples of what the other states
have done in terms of
an appropriation of american rescue plan
act funds uh would be
uh very helpful uh we have to get
through this moment and uh you know
that's really what we're focusing on
right now is uh just simply
uh survival and uh getting through this
moment and uh for for many providers it
feels like that's that's almost
impossible but i can say with respect to
this bill representative that
you know increasing the base rate uh by
five percent is something that you can
then build on uh going forward you'll
recall that in the previous biennium uh
medicaid rates for all classes of
providers were increased by 6.2 percent
there was two separate increases of 3.1
per annum
and so actually this increase is less
than that and we're amidst a uh pandemic
of you know just horrendous consequences
for all of health care so
uh you know whatever additional funding
uh this general court is willing to
provide uh would be greatly appreciated
but this is the minimum i think in terms
of what can be done
and i hate to be so gloomy but this is
just these are the facts are there any
thank you it sounds to me like what we
need to do is figure out what kind of
increase you need to be competitive with
the private market and not just in
health care but the private market
across the board and skilled jobs
and that that's the amount of money we
need to give you guys that that there is
a solution but that's what it is and
somebody we need the the money people to
crunch those numbers and figure out what
the rate increase is and then we need to
dig deep into our pockets and find that
money and make you guys competitive so
that the beds can be open because i will
use an example our dear friend who just
died this weekend was supposed to be
moved to a nursing home and they could
not find a nursing home bed for her
which would have kept her in the
hospital at a much greater cost than a
nursing home bed and that's what it
means not to have beds available and
that's really close and personal at home
for us
i want to express my sympathy for the
passing of representative rogers who's a
a very good person um it seems as too
too many good people in this uh general
court have passed uh of late
um and you're absolutely right i mean
that is a consequence uh you know it was
it was reference that there has been
sort of a piecemeal effort and by
calling a piecemeal i'm not disparaging
it but there's been a piecemeal effort
on the part of the state to try to ease
hospital capacity by providing some
staffing again through staffing agencies
to
certain nursing homes in order to
relieve some of that hospital backlog
but again piecemeal effort and so that
that problem still exists that that
those who are in the hospital setting
may not be able to access a nursing home
for discharge
and it's obviously inappropriate for
them to stay in the hospital setting and
of course if the state's a payer in that
instance it's going to cost a heck of a
lot more if the state's paying through
medicaid
we also have the situation where those
in home and community-based services
which we fully support by the way
may need to step up not forever but may
need to step up to a nursing home level
of care and if they are unable to do
that what's gonna happen they're gonna
end up in a hospital because they're
gonna get so sick that they're gonna end
up in a hospital and then irony of
ironies they won't be able to be
discharged to a nursing home because
there won't be a bed available so it
really is
a systemic problem it's all
interconnected i think as you point out
what happens with nursing homes affects
the home and community-based services
are there further questions
and
if i heard testimony correctly
over the course of
uh
the
22 biennium
you have received
some percentage in the nursing homes and
maybe this is a better question for hhs
but
um
i'm not exactly sure the law right now
the bills the law said 105
if you got three percent in one quarter
then i give you two percent to make up
for that
if i got one percent then do i give you
four percent
because i can't just give you an across
the board
five percent for
that whole time
because the nursing homes over time have
received something
so uh
that becomes
a nightmare
for
anyone to try to solve
if we go retroactive
and that if we start
one january or whatever whatever date it
is
on the calendar year
we may not have
that kind of horrible situation
to try to figure out that you got three
percent these were your costs this was
anyhow i just
mentioned that just just to answer uh
madam chair uh you know the department
was involved in the construct of this
legislation and some of the increases
that were referenced were really the
consequence of what's called the case
mix index and so
uh the acuity of the resonance the the
physical need of the residents and so
that will cause uh within the resources
appropriated by this body
that will cause the the rates to
obviously creep up and as was also
referenced uh there was a switch to a
new cost year uh during the biennium as
the basis for reimbursement that too
will also cause
things to creep up again that cost year
is only now 2019. we haven't entered the
pandemic cost years in terms of the
reimbursement but that will explain why
there has been some increase in the
rates
separate from this legislature's intent
to increase them by five percent
okay thank you very much thank you
anything else
uh
thank you
i now call on brooke belanger
i'm sorry that uh i didn't realize you
were here brooke and we would have had
you in earlier but uh thank you so much
for being here and i know that you are
the font of all answers so we wish that
were true oh it is it's got to be
certainly when uh director henry littman
is here this afternoon he will uh be
able to give you much more detail than i
can but i'm happy to do my best this i
i don't know if you want me to give you
a quick response to some of the
questions i heard or if you'd rather
direct the questions at me no i i think
that would be wonderful
okay
uh there was some conversation about the
language of no less than a hundred and
five percent if i could shed a little
rates are based on average rates for all
facil for all facilities rather than any
one facility and so you need that
language in there as a result of those
average rates for all facilities i would
also say that
adjusting a nursing facility rate and
giving them an across-the-board rate
increase as was intended by this body um
in hb2
there are a lot of different mechanisms
that contribute to the nursing facility
rate uh and so there are different
levers including the county cap that jim
monahan spoke about that
impact nursing facility reimbursement
and so
it's a little bit
harder to adjust and make that rate
increase with um
it's hard to make it just a blanket and
so these levers are there in place and
this bill is really a contingency plan
to ensure that the department is able to
the the committee has heard the
situation and is well aware of the
situation in nursing facilities but this
bill allows us to carry out the
directives of this body in hb2
i would also note that
there is a provision in here to ensure
that any unused funds would lapse so
that any concern of
um
spending more than that 105 percent
increase would come back
and would lapse but again that language
of no more than is is there because
rates are based on an average rate for
all facilities and as
brandon williams spoke about there's a
case mix index um there is
acuity rates there's utilization
as this body knows utilization has
decreased for a number of reasons
staffing a component of it
but if we see volume come back in the
next year of the biennium
there will be these funds will certainly
be
needed to ensure that we can meet that
are there any further questions
uh representative weiler
thank you madam chair
i am curious if we put five percent
increase in the budget why it wasn't
paid
there
the
effort to get the funds to the
facilities was done uh was carried out
by the department there are a number of
different funds that get used to pay out
the rates and i believe it was mr
monaghan who indicated that there is a
cascade of how funds get used
there are funds that are appropriated by
this body there are federal funds and
there are county funds
and so those get used to pay out the
rates and then there's the 504
account as well which gets paid out to
facilities so when using those different
levers and those different sources of
fund
the
efforts to meet those increases was out
there this bill ensures a and provides a
contingency to make sure that there are
sufficient funds to meet that intention
follow-up
i still don't understand why if we put
the five percent in the budget the
testimony seems to
indicate it never got paid
and you're not answering why
i apologize i don't mean to not be
answering your question so um there have
been rate increases um there have
to the facilities um
at different points in the year there
have been percentage increases um there
was also language in hb2 that
was the number of days um i believe that
impacted the ability to carry out that
rate increase
and
when director littman is here this
afternoon he can speak a bit more
articulately to that i don't want to um
swim above my my head if you will and
and give you the wrong information thank
you
representative edwards
uh thank you madam chair and um
okay so in the military we used to do
things called after action reviews after
you did it conducted an exercise
good bad or indifferent you you figured
out what what what went right and what
didn't go right okay we obviously did
something wrong
right because we we had the intent and
by we i mean me i was the chair of
division three
and i did not catch
whatever
the hb2 issues were that created this
cascade right so i'm not going to beat
myself up but what i would like to do
though
is to take your oral history
the oral history of mr monahan mr
lippman whoever else ms rounds
and and document it
in a nice tight description of exactly
what went wrong
so that we don't do this again
i'd really like to understand that okay
so um so if you could if you could maybe
prep mr lippman to speak to a document
that describes
in sort of an after-action review format
and i can give you that
uh i i want to know what we did wrong
because the legislature apparently put
some conflicting guidance in hb2
that when it got time to execute
at the department level
you guys got contradictory information
and failed to do what we intended you to
do so we just need to understand that is
that is that fair
we can
provide
a description of what the conflict was
uh what the language of conflict was and
the efforts that we have made
to meet those terms but i understand
what you're asking and we can bring that
back to you
and just so you know that's wholly
independent of whether or not i'm going
to support this legislation i i just i
just want to make sure that we
understand what went wrong thank you and
i don't and i i think representative
weiler doesn't fully understand it yet
either and i want to make sure i can
explain it to him
thank you i will make sure that the
committee has the information that
you've asked for all right thank you
i also might want to point out that um
although uh representative edwards
didn't give you kind of a timeline
uh it's short
okay
i am quite confident that director
littman can answer many of these um
specifics this afternoon for you and any
follow-up documentation that is needed
as soon as i get back to the office
we'll start working on okay thank you
because uh
i don't wanna anyhow
short is my problem but if we don't have
the right information then it becomes
everyone's problem
i am fairly confident in saying that
this afternoon many of these questions
will be cleared up and any additional
supporting documentation that the
committee would like we will make sure
we make that a high priority together
thank you
represent lynn you have a question
yes uh thank you madam chair um you know
can i go back to because i'm not quite
sure i understand the your explanation
of the no less than in other words if if
i understand correctly you said that you
need that language because the
reimbursement rates are determined on an
average
of of reimbursements to a group of
homes is that
a group of nursing homes is that correct
individual rates are set on a number of
factors case mix index so the acuity of
the individuals they are cost based
there are a number of factors that go
into the rates and so
it is
different than saying
we're going to set a five percent rate
on uh increase on a hundred dollars it's
not a a set base across the industry and
so because there are multiple factors
and in
there are different rates among
different facilities based on cost and
case mix index and a number of factors
that
language of no less than 105
is needed to ensure that they get the
rate increase
so may i ask a follow-up yes you may so
so am i understanding from that that
that what that means by what that
language would mean
is that
in the in other words to get to an
average that means it has to be some
above and some below and in my
understanding that what this language
would mean is that
effectively you would take the lowest
and make sure that that
that that that
that that reimbursement increased five
percent
with
presumably the result that there would
be that some that were above the average
would increase
more than five
percent so the goal is to ensure that
the five percent increase for hb2 is
carried out i want to if i could have
the opportunity to take that back and
confirm what the range would be i can
bring that back i understand that's an
important question and i don't want to
misspeak on what that would look like so
if i can have the opportunity to take
that back i will bring that information
thank you thank you
are there any further questions
representative thank you madam chair
thanks for the question i've heard it uh
several
several comments today about talking
about uh unused funds with laps not that
i anticipate there would be any unused
funds but where does it specifically
talk about lapsing funds
um
the in order to use these funds the
department has to make the request for
brooke it's not there
okay i apologize miners so i believe
it's built based on my understanding of
it was that we would only be able to
have the funds that were needed based on
an articulation and the request for
to be clear you weren't the only person
who said let that they would lap so
that's why i asked
i appreciate that
so i have a question of the chair oh me
please do you think i have an answer i
think on this one you might uh
is
because i was looking at this looking
for the same language whether the word
non-lapse or lapse was used and and
because it's not in here i'm just
curious do do we do we just assume
all monies that we appropriate in a
two-year cycle are to lapse unless we've
explicitly said non-lapsing and because
we haven't specified non-lapsing in here
does this mean this defaults to to
elapse
and that's probably why it doesn't say
anything in here
because it always
that's the way it goes
okay are there any further questions for
brooke
all right seeing none
whoops thank you very much
thank you
and i have no one on the blue sheet that
hasn't testified
so i
thank you and
for those of us on the fiscal committee
we'll get back together at one o'clock
and i believe most of the divisions are
meeting at three
so
we'll see you then
okay
yes
[Music]
oh
um
foreign
hey
you